we're here at CES unveiled at the ion
audio booth now I think everybody should
know how to play an instrument and ion
audio is trying to make that a lot
easier with their apprentice series this
is a series of instruments that have an
iPad dock in them you stick your iPad in
and they have apps for keyboards guitars
and drums that teach you how to play
with full tutorials the keys I'd up
showing you where you should hit or
strum or play or poke and they actually
have video instructors as well teaching
you music theory this is the keyboard
apprentice this comes in three sizes
that up to a full size keyboard there's
also guitar apprentice with light up
fretboard to show you where to put your
fingers and then the drum apprentice
which you can just whack away like
you're playing guitar hero but you're
actually learning how to play the drums
these are all $99 the keyboard
apprentice is out now the guitar
apprentice and drum apprentice come out
in June
I